i'll talk to you every night okay i
promise
i love you lots same those big
challenges coming
i'm literally shaking right now
i'm just sat here in the car with samuel
leeds if you don't know who he is
just googling but he's a
multi-millionaire entrepreneur king
you're [ __ ] pumped we just left this
family
stripped from always wealth i haven't
quite gotten that much
to dive in this wild adventure what are
we doing let's get down to business i've
been stripped from everything so i'm
starting all over again from scratch
i've been dumped into a random city
sheffield
you're gonna be using an alias name i
think you made it really hard
i probably wouldn't do it if i haven't
made any money in the next seven days i
will be evicted from my hotel and be on
the streets
nibble on them for the week i've got 50
pound in my pocket for basic potentials
i'm not eating today at all it'll be in
the bag
but i need to start building my property
portfolio again from scratch with
nothing let's see what happens
within two weeks i've never seen
anything like this before i'm
documenting everything this is the
financial freedom challenge
it's my home for the week tuesday i'm
gonna go straight to right move
if i can find a hmo in sheffield and it
should feel really that expensive
so here's the html let's see if we can
get a view
i think i need to set up an email
address
um yeah i do um it's uh luca
lucas dot ruby
yep one one one
literally just showing me more viewings
on the spot you mean potentially
yeah it's just too easy this is how you
get in
tomorrow i just want to be viewing
properties just like all
day and then the day after i go
networking and i'm going to sell what i
found
but first let's get the deals in the bag
every
15 minutes there's beautiful apartments
coming on
gumtree open rent with landlords renting
out these apartments
for like 600 pounds for the whole
apartment
i know that hotels are fully booked all
through sheffield i know that because i
struggled getting this hotel booked
a hotel average where i went out for a
hundred pound a night i can turn
that apartment into a hotel so all i
need to do is get the landlord to agree
and everything's okay for me to give me
600 a month and then i will then rent it
out as a hotel
and make loads of profit and put down
nothing
so that's a strategy that i'm looking at
and i just need to get in front of
people
so let's do this my name's lucas i buy
apartments and rent them out
and i also um have a have a management
company where i take on apartments and
rent them out of service accommodation
in that area
oh wow you show me around show me what
you've got available i just want to see
it man
so now i've already got one guy who's
going to show me his hmo which is a
really good hmo i've got a second
agent who's going to show me hmo and
loads of other potential hmos and
interesting stuff all morning and now
i've got this contact with this mega
landlord who owns a whole bar
well right now it's a game but also i
need to eat in a week
hi kirk i just wonder if you can help me
i've got a pot of money
and i'm looking at buying some
properties in the area i want to get on
that hot list of yours
have you got anything available at the
moment well okay so my email is
lucas i could just do this all day man
she's just
shame i haven't got any money tell us
about this pot of money that you were
talking about
i'm i'm prophesying about a pot of money
that an investor has and the investor
wants me to find him a deal and he'll
pay me
now this investor i haven't met him yet
he exists
and i will find him in the next few days
and then i'll hook him up
with these estate agents and then i'll
make money and then with that money
i will put that down towards my own
property portfolio owner of this indian
restaurant in sheffield
we're now neighbours yes and he's told
me that if i if i fail as a property
entrepreneur
i always have a job here you're welcome
it's the middle of the night i have to
pick up some stuff from the room
i'm just doing some comparables all
right
dude it's midnight
you are crazy really exciting numbers
there okay
you got it this is what i do man all day
every day do my thing
all right calm it down
right that was very bad on my part but
it did save us five minutes
tight tight on time so we're all meeting
we're meeting peeps got this
wonderful hmo to show us and potentially
more lined up but
when they say potentially more lined up
sometimes that's when you get the
absolute gold dust
the best thing is to just find out what
they want and then see if you can give
it to them and then work the numbers out
afterwards
dude this is like a really important
view yes thank you
crap i think it's the battery but this
i'm gonna call an uber
because we can't miss this viewing i
can't leave the car here all day
please
please just wait 10 minutes that's not
his battery
sometimes something bad but it's still
funny
um he is the definition of a tired
landlord there
has a big problem on his hands the
question is can i solve his massive
problem
of having all these hmos that are
completely run down
he doesn't have the energy to continue
managing them he doesn't have the
finance to do them up
he's not really prepared to do any kind
of joint venture or anything at all
creative like a flat guaranteed rent or
something or
because he's almost 80 and he's just
like just
you know so i would buy them and i would
get rid of all the tenants
and i would turn them into either luxury
apartments or
do it as a nice professional house share
60 70 would you consider
had a good chat with him at first he was
quiet no
cold and standoffish he looked like he
was just angry with life almost
rather personal questions towards the
end he was quite
complimentary we will take a bmv offer i
could i could do two or three
cash for aj so now
we've got more viewings uh later on car
is broken and we are stranded
over a mile away from the car how are we
going to get batman
we've got we've got to get back to the
car i sat because we've got all our
stuff we've got a mechanic he's going to
be in 15 minutes
we are 26 minutes away so let's walk
fast thank god my knee is better
because my knee broken badly pretty
when we broke down here we were like
what a terrible place to break down
you know we're blocking the road it's
double yellows now it's like oh yeah
it's standard man everyone
easter but how much fuel was still left
i know i was like oh it's doing so well
for fuel
it's running perfect what can i do or
anything
you're so grateful thank you for saving
my day
i was just topping up petrol and i told
him that i was new to sheffield and i
just come here to be a property
entrepreneur he said property
entrepreneur and he gave me some
back stories of motivated sellers with
empty houses why are they going so cheap
42 000. if i get a deal i'll have to
come back and buy you a drink
oh thanks so much never assume oh he's
just the petrol man or
this person's just the mechanic
everyone's got the story and everyone's
got something to give so
fantastic man see that's the kind of
thing that would make sure
you can make some serious money on
putting off a big project like this
is gonna take weeks and weeks maybe
months
and i need cash right now
so i'll see i'll be there at 12 30 and
really look forward to meeting you thank
you
so weird being called lucas it feels
like i'm an absolute fraud
[Laughter]
lovely apartment two bedrooms absolutely
love erina
the letting agent these ones are on for
6.50
yes as far as the least is concerned if
we were going to do it as a um
on booking.com okay booking.com.com yeah
yeah okay
okay so right now do you only have one
available i'm sure we got two
awesome awesome awesome we basically
have a deal
two apartments one penthouse and this
one comes furnished
i think we'll probably get it for 12.50
spoke to the
developer who owns all this site he was
asking me questions i was thinking he
was the cleaner
and um he's good yeah we're happy
basically you want
their house to be in very good condition
nice people money paid i've checked all
that
i'm really excited i think we're about
to make some good money and also have a
longevity relationship with this guy as
well
came to sheffield yesterday with no
money and i'm sat in the office with a
multi-millionaire
for half an hour um with my little
yellow car
he was saying like you know tell me
about your story
where do you live and i was telling him
i live in a house chef i'll get i'll get
there one day
owning a whole state like this i
couldn't tell him that i'm a property
millionaire
samuel leeds had to keep the story going
otherwise
people watching this might say the only
reason he did business with you is
because you're a millionaire like him
but actually he doesn't know i'm a
millionaire he thinks i'm a broke
dude who's probably just finished una
come to sheffield because i've broken up
from my girlfriend or something who
knows
driving this car the fact that i can do
business with him
it's not because of my status it's
because of my
ability and skill and then the 12 50
times straight so all together it comes
down to 5
700. you know because the paint house is
quite a lot
maybe we could get like a one-month
deposit and then you can
pay monthly rather than having three
months okay
that's cool yeah so 4450 you're gonna
need obviously my
um idea yes company name is there
anything else you need for me
you need to know that you can afford to
pay it okay that's as simple as that
yeah
what do you need to say because i mean
it is a new company so are you
registered in the company house
so these apartments that i've just
secured and hopefully we'll be getting
the keys on monday next week
wanna make them into a hotel but i need
to get someone
or some system to manage it so that it's
passive income
scheduled right now with a service
accommodation booking company as far as
the management concerned
they're going to take it off the booking
so i don't expect anything upfront to do
the training i'm having to pay
about to do whatever i need to do and
booking should start coming in next week
oh i've just got another appointment
that's a four bed hmo for a hundred
thousand pounds
perfect condition so i can sell that now
before i even view it
and if it falls through it's not as good
as i think then i'll cross that bridge
time to get some money in the bank now
tell me all about it good news is i've
got some deals the bad news
is i haven't got money to buy the deals
so i need to sell them
so the only event anytime soon is
actually in birmingham
so the good news is i will see you
tonight
bad news is because it's in birmingham i
need to be disguised
and i was wondering if i can cut your
wig up and wear it tomorrow
ah come on amanda take one for the team
hello hello it's 99 hello how are you
austin
he's hiding i'm glad you're not live oh
my god
transformation
hello i'm lucas ruby and i'm here today
to
learn about property so today's mission
is to raise 4850 pounds
and that is gonna then go towards these
two uh rent to end deals with these
luxury apartments
that i have already secured and have
told that i have the money in place
man man is this risky we're loving it
like that
this is extra awkward because there's
going to be people in the room don't
particularly like me and
know about the challenge and think it's
stupid avastifyan can lead the way
at registration and i'll just be his
choir you are not here
yesterday young and
i think today is going to be building
relationships day
tomorrow is going to be sale day that's
what i think because we've got to sow
the seeds and build the relationship no
one's going to just give you five grams
when they've just met yeah but tomorrow
if if they like me and they've built a
relationship and they think this is real
and the deal is good enough and me
yeah have a real talk we could do so
uh talking of options i've just secured
a really uh
nice lease option agreement even some of
the trainers
are quite interested in securing it so
it's like
you need to go yeah well what's the
figures it was like he was so interested
i
almost had a handshake with him i felt
assuming that all the things that i've
said are
accurate are you would you want to go
ahead and i put my hand out and he was
like well
i've only just met you like 10 minutes
ago you know
oh close i think i'll get him i think
i'll get him
so a guy called lee who's sad
recommended me to
has just called me but i didn't want to
pick up because it was so noisy i've
just text him
and uh i'm warming him up over text
right now getting ready to phone him
later and get some money
here's the thing
i've got some really good deals the
problem is
i need 4 850 pounds in order to secure
the deals
so today i've been trying to just kind
of blag my way
to get the money by just offering people
deals
which worked to a point i did win people
over
but i didn't win them over enough for
anybody to actually
pull their credit card out this is
harder than i thought
i mean all i need is 4850 pounds i need
it by monday
i'm struggling so it's day four
yes today's day four oh my goodness it's
day four i'm hoping to sell a deal today
or at least get some money in my bank
because
day seven is my last day of my hotel if
i've got money by day seven i'm getting
kicked out i want to get my list
tomorrow to 50 people
which i think i can easily do with
leverage of tapping into other people's
contacts
it's not do you want to buy ideas who do
you know that wants to buy a deal there
might only be 60 people in the room but
if everyone knows a thousand people
there's actually 60 000 people in the
room so when i'm in a room like that i'm
seeing 60 000 potential people that i
could tap into
this car by the way feels feels like
it's about to break down
no again not oh my
goodness
we're broken on the freaking motorway
this is not even
safe oh this this this is a
right off that is very dangerous what
number do you call for that
here in the uk you know what i normally
drive a brand new car
that never breaks down it's not cyphers
luckily lawsuit that's the most very
true yeah very true
he could have gone video clicking you
reckon garyvee will be jealous of
documentary
i think he'll be thinking i'd rather you
than me
if we manage it still your profit will
be maybe six fifty seven hundred each
month will be your profit
introduce you to young because jan's my
business partner save you would like to
secure
the rental rent that we've got in
sheffield but she's basically wants to
go for it we're gonna put a three-month
break clause in there
so that if it's not renting out we know
it will yeah but if it's not renting out
we can then refund her in full and and
we'll take the property back
i think it's a goer good to meet you
thank you so much
good to meet you how come you're wearing
a microphone
oh i am samuel yes you are samuel yes
so what are the commentaries
that was something else right now we
have no car
no money we've been kicked out of the
networking event
but we do have a deal we just need to
find a joint venture partner do you
reckon i'll publicly say something
oh right now i'm feeling
really stressed out because
tomorrow morning i'm meeting with the
agent
and i'm supposed to be paying and
signing
for these two properties and i have zero
in my bank
nothing i had one guy who was meeting
tomorrow with the agent and i was going
to try and sell to him
with the agent to then get the money
to pay eleanor the agent and now i can't
get hold of him and it's gone midnight
oh my goodness
this is really bad
yan i need to tell you something
come on dude the great news
is he got back to me yes and he wants to
meet me this morning come on the bad
news is he thinks i'm lucas and he
thinks i have silly hair and glasses so
we need to get this guy
absolutely
lucas is back in town
he's just messaged me and i'm on my way
and i really think he's gonna buy it i
really do it's an incredible deal
if i get the money from him i'm pretty
much
guaranteed to be able to get these deals
ready to do business i've done all the
hard work i've been networking for days
i want to be able to introduce everyone
i don't want to be late and then they
all get talking when i'm not there i
want to be able to control the scene
see the figures see what you can do and
then you'll probably be able to think of
a way to get the money i think
when you know how much you're going to
be getting back and when you see the
properties i know i've taken the two
apartments
i was potentially interested in the
third one and there's already properties
in the block that are being used as
service accommodation
yeah it's already happening just spent a
whole morning with someone
who was like yeah i'm gonna do the deal
and all this but actually
isn't prepared to put any money down at
all
asking a million among questions right
now he's expecting me to try and hard
close him
he's ready for it and he's got his guard
up i'm not going to do it i'm just going
to go anyway
have a great day
really cool um and i'll say you know i
don't think you're right for actually
because you've got no and you're like
i am he can sell himself that's what you
get for being standoffish
well if you want to make me an offer on
the properties that we've seen
that you know make me an offer by all
means you've seen you've seen what's
you've seen the property you've seen the
figures um
i'm not an expert big problem really i
need to i've just told ellen that i'm
going to put
down 4850 pounds i was banking on this
guy
so now i think i'm gonna have to do a
pretend payment that should be uh
with you in the next few hours
and then just wait for it to chase me
and in the meantime work like crazy to
raise the funds i feel a bit sick
actually about this money though
she'll be she might be handing in like
literally two hours
let's go about three minutes
oh goodness as expected eleanor
is now chasing for the money for the
rent to rent that we're really backing
on
i think if i try and sell today oh my
goodness she wants that money because if
she pulls the plug on these properties
yeah then in two days i'm out of my
hotel
and i'm evicted and i'm living on the
streets
i need to be emailing those deals out
lucas speaking how can help i've been
told that you're pretty pretty ready to
go and things like that i'm going to
tell you about the one that i
personally like best which i think would
sell really really quickly if i emailed
it out blitz it into two apartments and
just rent it out as apartments
that's my favorite so that's the one
that i think is going to go really
really fast for you is that what you're
looking for
yeah yeah i just need a few minutes to
think about it if you don't buy it i'm
not emailing it out i'm gonna
i'm gonna try and borrow the money and
buy it myself but you reserve a property
you'll have to pay the finders fee
that's powerful man that's called that's
called leverage in people
but instead of trying to do business
with just those people that you know you
say who else do you know who else do you
know and then you can grab a ripple and
get hold of a lot more people
so i'm suddenly my network is growing so
fast as lucas ruby
even though i was exposed in the room
they'd already given me details yeah and
if you want i can
send you on the account number again
just in case
um yeah i'll have to check with my bank
and see uh see what's going on my end
that is stressful mate
yeah that could just fail the challenge
that good
so i'm just writing the heads of terms
for sean just so we've got a clear
understanding and agreement together so
there's no ifs and butts later if he
comes back then he's not happy
all right so sean's got to 11
within a quarter of an hour that's the
deadline that i gave you yeah
and he said he'd try his best to get the
terms sent back to me by then
but oh my gosh babe
i have just sold a deal
come on hey money in the bank hey
i've currently got nothing in the bank
at all
it's the sixth day so it's almost like
at the last hour but that money i'm not
gonna be able to use towards living
that's gonna go towards my uh rent to
rent deals
and that came babe from a contact from a
contact
but when i get evicted from my hotel
i'll be able to stay
at my own house so if i wanted to i
could just stay there
and rent out the other rooms and just
live rent
forever and i've just done that
literally from scratch as lucas
i need to sell another deal in order to
get my
my full amount of money if i can sell a
deal tonight
at this networking event i am made
so at the networking event when there
was an opportunity to ask a question i
asked a question
that let the whole room know that i had
a deal
but it kind of backfired on me i just
want some quick cash um but yeah it is
tempting to keep but okay
so sorry i just want to say is that
samuel
yeah yeah okay
anyway so it matters about my deal
not about my name yes
exposed again for the second time this
time at least i didn't get kicked out or
thrown out and then it made it really
difficult for me to sell at the end i
did
try and sell still however and i have
got some calls and appointments tomorrow
with people that do not know
that i am samuel leeds uh i don't even
think they know who samuel is which is
just
perfect so still hoping to get the money
in because i really need the money
tomorrow
otherwise i'm gonna be evicted
i was really banking on getting some
money tonight
i'm gonna be chased like crazy tomorrow
oh do do do you need to record this she
recorded she wants to buy the regiment
deal off me i'm sure
and i met her yesterday and she thinks i
am lucas so it was really nice meeting
you yesterday
let's just give it a go and if it
doesn't work then well then you i'll
i'll pay you back your fee
and i'll take the property on you know
myself initially that sounds great
actually
yeah okay thank you so much for the call
and um
i'll hear from you later
she got such a good deal it's painful
giving it away
for three thousand i'd love to keep it
for myself but i need three thousand and
you know what if she says in three
months and she wants my money back
great i'll keep it myself it's just like
it's all coming together man
it's almost getting to the point now
where if the rent to rent deals fell
through
i wouldn't even care i think you've got
a really good property so
congratulations for securing
another great deal and um i'll drop you
an email in terms of conditions in the
next sort of 20 minutes
i'm so pleased about that call because
that means i have enough money in the
bank
to do the rent to end deals as soon as
he pays it
i can pay for the rent to rent deals
which means
i should be financially free tomorrow
yay
but i'm not happy at that because i want
at least one lease option agreement here
in the bag
i'm getting the keys on friday i'm
waiting on money coming in the bank
from deals that i've sourced and sold so
now i'm just going to try and press on
and see if i can get a police option
agreement
because i think that would just be epic
i'm just looking for how
a cheap house for sale man typically you
need to phone 10 people to get a lease
option agreement at least
so a lease option agreement is when you
buy a property now but you pay for it
later
but in the meantime you benefit from the
rent and the capital appreciation it can
be over five
seven years in your situation i could
possibly do a
do a set up where i rent it off you and
give you a guaranteed rent
and then buy it off you over a period of
time okay this one says urgent
if you want to do it do you want to try
come on hello hey hello this is jan
speaking the rent
to buy scheme is it something that that
we can talk about
i certainly will think about it can we
come for reviewing
200 pounds a month guaranteed rent we
would pay for all the repairs we would
even
give the house a little bit of a refurb
in four years time we'd bite off you for
70 000 pounds the
agreement is drawn up properly it's
legally binding by solicitors
so if you want to have a chat with them
what do you think
he's got 10 of these houses he doesn't
want the hassle anymore he's tired of
managing them he doesn't need the money
perfect candidate he's stressed he's
like oh
he can't sell it once he spoke to my
solicitor i really will help him out
take away all that stress and in
exchange
i'll get a free house
thank the good lord you know what that
means that means
that we can pay helena which means that
tomorrow we pick up the keys
to two rent to rent deals oh my goodness
come on but
i'm quickly realizing it's not all about
the money it's just about having a good
lifestyle
any cash that i've still got left over
from sourcing or whatever
i think we should just give it away
maybe give it away to people that really
are struggling
that will make me feel much happier i
love receiving but giving
brings real joy but you can't give
unless you can receive
make you'll make it all worthwhile it's
so important to have
people that are rooting for you um and
just just dare to say
come on i think that's just so important
mold support
no one's an island i couldn't do this on
my own good to see you again yeah guess
what
good news i don't need a job anymore got
some property deals
i made it just like you said so thank
you for believing in our friends thank
you thank you we thought we'd come and
celebrate
all my work is done this morning is the
morning
that i'm gonna be picking up the keys to
my two rent to rent deals
oh come on another 3 000
in the bank third deal thank god for
that that means that even if i don't get
the keys now at least i can sleep
somewhere tonight
believe it 8 000 pounds financial
freedom in a week
i feel embarrassed why
because it's almost like a taboo getting
so much money such a short amount of
time
i can't believe how easy it has been but
at the same time
people's pain are being relieved getting
good deals win-win situations
so i'm impressed i'm really really
impressed
that means it's a done deal so the
keypad is going to be right here
here which means that people can just
come and they'll type the code in and
then they'll be able to go in
and out and then the cleaners will come
and get it ready for the next person
one three nine seven plus one two
three oh if all goes to plan i'm making
a total profit off the two properties
of 2 600
per month which is gonna mean i'm one
very happy boy
you think that's realistic based on what
you've seen and what you know
yeah looking at it going through the
numbers going through the processes
all i can say is well done to samuel
leeds
yes she is in a redeemed yellow car
why not show you around oh yes please
i'm excited
we'll rent out this one on average for
about 160 pounds a night
and then downstairs we'll went that one
out for about 120 pounds
should be in theory making considerably
over two thousand pounds a month profit
so i think i've smashed the three
thousand pound in my financial freedom
in a week
[Music]
well i'll be coming home tonight yeah
i'm finished
oh well done oh my gosh
i'm more excited about giving these
gifts tomorrow
than i even was about picking up the
keys to the deal and we're gonna be
meeting a guy called sid who runs a
charity
where he takes homeless people off the
streets um brings them onto a big
bus and then finds them uh council
houses and things like that
people will be of us two three months on
average every night
where we're parking they can use showers
at the building initially it's about
getting that rest back because people
are getting sort of an average of two
hours of sleep per night so people miss
meetings
best people i met that there were two
homeless guys who snuck on sorry we've
not touched anything we're just curious
whose doorbest is it it's like well kind
of it's yours actually
yeah i just said i believe god wants you
to know that you're valuable
yeah and that you're a very important
person too you're a vip
and he just burst into tears we do have
a little gift for you keep up the good
work
this came at such a crazy time because
well this broke down
yeah i managed to block junction one of
the m60 and then i got your phone call
that amount two ground there that's
pretty much exactly what
we need so welcome last year in the uk
over 400 people died on the street just
sleeping out in cold
so you may well have station by that's
what it means oh mate that felt
so good didn't it like my stomach i had
a really bad tummy but now i suddenly
feel a lot better
what an amazing work he's doing yeah
dude i love the word
giving that phone to the mechanic yeah
wow his boss thinks he's going to be
over the moon with it so
when you help me out i was in a massive
tomorrow night and i heard your phone
broke so i got you a new
samsung galaxy fan also some cinema
tickets to with the messes
okay so something ridiculously exciting
has just happened after becoming
financially free
i decided to go to dubai where it's nice
and warm and uh stay at this beautiful
hotel
and literally while i've been here my
phone keeps pinging and i'm getting
bookings
left right and center from booking.com
literally let me show you what i'm
talking about right now check this out
you won't believe this
new booking new booking new booking look
at this new booking
new booking and also like i'm also
getting that's just booking.com i'm also
getting them on airbnb
look at this stephanie she says really
looking forward to staying in your flat
looks lovely
i've also been getting messages from
some of the estate agents even the guy
who said no about a lease option
agreement has come back to me and said
maybe actually yes
it's incredible this is all systemized
i'm here lying on the beach while this
is all happening
that truly is passive income that truly
is financial freedom and you know what
if i can do that
you can do that too if with a little bit
of hard work in one week i can achieve
that
just imagine what you can achieve in
maybe one year with the right knowledge
and the right implementation
you know what financial freedom is for
absolutely anybody
you